hot breath skip asks what's a writing
exercise
or discipline you use frequently
i try to do i used to sit down and write
before sets
like just trying to churn out jokes um
individual jokes
but i found that to be it was i could
see that you know you do something and
then you see the result of it so my
first album like that's what i did
and then i listened to the album it's
like great jokes but
okay on the next one i would like to
have great jokes but i would like it to
be more organic
so in order for that to happen you have
to change your process which is
instead of just joke writing i'm going
to still joke right but i'm going to
journal now
and then i'm going to take the organic
situations that happen in my life and
i'll apply my joke writing ability
to that instead of just trying to sit
down and grind out jokes
i need a marriage joke i need a gambling
joke i need a
something so it's like i used to do that
i need a marriage joke a gambling joke a
sex joke i need
this and instead now it's just like okay
what's happening in your life take it
write it and then apply the joke writing
um your strategy to to what's already
happening
so instead of trying to yeah find
material you almost look at what's
already
easily accessible to you and write it
from there
right unless it's like a comedy seller
show
on comedy central where they'll give you
topics and they're like okay here's the
topics and that's kind of the challenge
because it's like
okay we're all doing like these are the
topics what can you find
you know and then it's a different it's
now it's like look at the angles
what are some of the angles and then i
don't really journal on that i just look
at the angles
and then maybe there's something here
maybe there's something here maybe
there's something here
and because it has to be taped in a
timely fashion i'll
video what my thoughts are on it i'll
video my thoughts and then i'll watch it
and be like oh maybe there's something
there i can tighten up something there
much like a set there's something there
i can tighten up that's an idea but not
ready
that's not done and then and then keep
shooting it until i craft
the points that i want and it it helps
you
what helps me you'll write you'll write
a joke
and then record yourself doing it and
refine it that way
yeah i'll give a topic and then i'll go
okay what are the what are the angles
here on this
and and i'll write the angles and then
try to do a cohesive
video of it like a video just for myself
because you're going on stage that night
so it's like and you and
you you maybe you got the you got the
topics the day before
so there's no time so it's just like you
take
all right kids we're back
okay okay we're back here so what i just
did
is um i just connected my computer
to um my phone's internet so
just know hot breath we're draining the
data for this one we're using the whole
data plan
to get this interview but i think we're
good now actually
so this is going to be great my mom will
be my mom will be thrilled i used up all
her data don't worry
so what it kind of cut out
a little bit that is interesting i
didn't know this comedy seller show did
that though
to where it was like okay here are your
topics you have a day to write them
and then we're going to film them for um
like the internet that's pretty that's
wild i didn't know that's how they did
that well depending when you're shooting
you're typing you could be shooting on a
day you could be shooting in two days
you know it just depends when you're
shooting but uh the point is you don't
have that much time with the topic
so it's like and you don't have time to
really try it out so it's like you've
got to get
this thing out and then it's a different
process than
it then like trying to work it in the
clothes for a while you know
good practice and you mentioned putting
you look for the angles so what do what
do you mean by angles exactly
um the angles uh
well i'm trying to think of the just
like
the corona virus with you know before we
got quarantined
it's like okay it's write something
about it was kind of a broad thing but
write something about the coronavirus
and it's like okay what are the angles
like
why are we like i guess what i mean by
angles is like questions
you're questioning the topic okay ah how
did we get it
why did we have it you know so i
i came up with uh um we have
it because people told us to get rid of
straws
people told us to get rid of straws now
we're putting our mouths on everything
and uh the turtles are fine but now we
all have the coronavirus like we're
dying
uh-huh the angle is did the turtles care
about us
we care about the turtles and now we
need help and the turtles don't give a
i mean and then it's like their heads
are in they're in their shells
you know they're old you know there's
more jokes about them being old and then
um mumbling racial slurs in their shells
because they're a hundred
so it's like i guess what i mean by
angles is she's like you're you're
questioning the topic you're asking
questions let me close this up there's a
light coming through here yeah no
problem
yeah a little a little backlight as they
say
so thank you for everyone commenting
with questions as well and sticking with
us through this internet
debacle here hopefully this data plan
holds up
so yeah so the angles are the questions
um i was following a train of thought
there
you know because it's never it's never
dead on the topic it's always like an
ancillary thing
it's always like an it's always a you
give it you know
straight on you have to you have to
angle it to be like okay what's funny
about this
you know and will you like write the
time it's usually the little things it's
usually the little things that are funny
oh interesting okay like them like the
turtles saying the racial slur you mean
like little details like that
is usually what's the funny little
details but uh it's like
how are we getting it what what you know
what would have prevented it
and then taking another like pop culture
thing that we just
went through which is like there was a
whole big initiative before all this
started to get rid of
straws so i connected to the whole
which people are well aware of and
everybody supported so it's like get rid
of straws like
oh maybe that caused it maybe the straw
people are the
gotcha so you almost like here's a pop
culture topic
what are other pop culture topics i
could maybe
connect it with and find that's one way
to find an angle
yeah it's a it's a the problem is this
and the solution might also be
out there like okay you know what is the
solution maybe
maybe vaping maybe another problem is
the solution
you know oh that's gold i love that
and you'll just write the topic like at
the top of your page
and then just kind of start
brainstorming these things that's kind
of the
the pen to paper process
yeah well i was flying back from i was
flying back from somewhere
and i got the topic so it's like okay i
got to work on this on the flight
so it's like it it helps to like read
the
for me it helps to like read the news
and and go back to writing
and then read the news more because
there's angles in the news where it's
like oh this is happening this is
happening
this is happening and then you take it
all into consideration and be like okay
what are the angles of this joke what
are the what are the angles of the
coronavirus
what are the angles of the quarantine
you know i mean yeah we're stuck
together
um you know everything is something else
maybe that's the angle you know it's
like
uh i don't know i'm just like like
you're being playful with it
you know you're not settling on any one
thing but it's you it helps to talk it
out
but it also if you can't talk it out if
you're you're just writing down
maybe you don't have the full joke but
maybe in your quarantine
it's your own little society so
everything is everything else
the bathroom is a hospital my closet is
a gym
um my uh the other room is a summer home
you know what i mean it's like
you just you're you're being playful
with it it's like is that something
maybe that's not funny enough you know
it's like
keep playing with it until i get it